oh my god you guys I have to tell you
this story so I'm flying so I do an
episode of Kroll show and always working
with Nick Kroll you're guaranteed you're
gonna laugh your ass off all [ __ ] day
can I kiss the kids ask any Michael of
him I think he's I think he's a [ __ ]
genius so anyways I go I go to the
airport and I'm taking the red-eye
taking this 1055 flight knowing [ __ ]
stop cuz that's how I do it alright I'm
on a good plane why would I want to get
off it and switch and roll the dice and
get on another one you know let's just
[ __ ] get there when it when I Drive
up to San Francisco I don't pull over
and [ __ ] Burbank and then getting hit
no another cut we get it built alright
so I get on the [ __ ] plane right I
use my miles bump myself up like a fancy
person you know maybe maybe I invented
the Cheesecake Factory people are
thinking and then they see how I'm
dressed and I go oh no he did invent the
Cheesecake Factory
um and I go to go to sit down on my seat
and I go to set my bag down I was gonna
set it down right in front of me and the
nice fella sitting next to me goes once
you stick it in the middle of his room
and he moved his bag out of the way I'm
like all right this guy's a solid dude
or whatever and then all of a sudden the
waitress comes by a stewardess whatever
she comes by flight attendant whatever
the [ __ ] he's supposed to call him she
comes up and she could I get you jelly
to drink and I was like yeah can I get
out let me get a water please
ice or no ice what however you make it
stop acting like it's a [ __ ] martini
it's wall right just give me a water
with ice thank you and the guy next to
me he orders a Dewar's knee no ice no
nothing just put it in there so they
bring our drinks all right and I'm
really thirsty so I start sucking mine
down and he just throws his back like
it's nothing like [ __ ] John Wayne
right before he's gonna turn around and
beat up three guys three mustachioed
guys in the 1930s right so I'm just
sitting there and everybody's getting on
the flight you know
I'm looking around at the passengers you
know I'm [ __ ] doing whatever I'm
doing and all of a sudden the guy next
to me mr. Dewar's goes to me he goes
excuse me he goes are you afraid to fly
and I looked at I was like what he goes
are you afraid to fly and I go no no I'm
not and he goes you guys all right but
you know it's he goes it's okay you know
it it's okay to tell me if you afraid to
fly and it's immediately getting weird
and I'm like no I'm not afraid to fly
and then I'm thinking in my head wait is
he afraid to fly
and that's why he's drinking the way he
just drank and now he's hoping that I'm
gonna be afraid to fly so he you know he
just wants to open up that's what I'm
thinking and I'm like yeah no I'm not
afraid to fly and he won't leave it
alone he goes alright because you know
you're you're you're fidgeting you're
looking around at other passengers and
I'm looking at like is this guy [ __ ]
serious and I go no I go I'm not afraid
to fly so now I'm like [ __ ] this guy I'm
not talking this guy for less this
flight this guy's weird man it's like
thirty just get paint the pictures like
thirty two-year-old wiry in shape but
like wiry white dude he's got a Scully
cap on with [ __ ] glasses you know and
he goes uh like there's like a minute of
silence and people still getting on the
plane and then he goes hey sorry about
that sorry we just we just got off on
the wrong foot he's like my name is
so-and-so he goes what's your name and
then I'm thinking of my head like what's
my name my name is Frank I wanted to
give him like a flyby just some reason I
just wanted it's Bill you guys oh hey
Bill he goes nice to meet you so we
shake hands and I'm just looking at I
don't have any poker face I'm looking at
the guy like what the [ __ ] is your
problem I'm not even trying to not I'm
not trying to be pleasant I'm already
done with this guy so then the guy goes
oh hey Bill he goes why you going to
Indianapolis bill right like he's
[ __ ] interrogating
and I I'm like is this gonna [ __ ]
serious and I start doing the math in my
head go wait is this guy like an air
marshal or something I'm like no he's
not he's [ __ ] slamming booze over
here [ __ ] this guy so I just go I go
look I don't I don't have to answer your
questions that's it and I just looked
straight forward
he goes okay now I'm concerned okay
I am concerned and I'm looking at him
like concerned about what because you're
fidgeting you're you you have issues
with other passengers and blah blah blah
all he's such Payton like like this like
he's been I don't know what the [ __ ]
like psychologically breaking me down
all right so now just by this point
they've closed the [ __ ] the door to
the fuselage and we're starting to taxi
and I just finally look at the guy and I
go I go
you know I came up with the fight one
point I literally stick my hand out
because he kept saying I was nervous and
I stick my hand right in front of his
face and I hold it level oh that's what
I did the first time yeah I hold it
level I go I'm not nervous and he goes
well anybody can do that and that's when
I was like [ __ ] this guy I'm not talking
to the guy sorry [ __ ] the story up then
Denny Denny came back got my name now
he's going why are you going to
Indianapolis and I finally look at him I
say listen pal I'm drinking waters
you're drinking doers okay there's no
issue over here and then he goes it
wasn't doers what she gave me wasn't
doers really what was it some sort of
spy juice you [ __ ] jerk-off this
point I want to punch him right through
his [ __ ] stupid wiry glasses right so
he's going like you looking around
hostels and I said something that just
ticked him off I was his head dude I go
I don't have to answer your questions
alright leave me alone and then he goes
he goes dual egos he starts going like
okay I am really concerned right now he
was why you going to Indianapolis and I
just look at him you know when I start
doing I start doing like this Ryan
Gosling you know that little smirk that
[ __ ] mono Lisa smile he has is he
smirks his way through all this [ __ ]
movies I do but I go full-on
goslings now I'm not talking to this guy
and I just keep looking at him and I
gave him that little half-ass mark and I
just shake my head that's my game now
that's this is Mike it's like if you're
gonna be a dick right now with your
[ __ ] delusional authority right that
you're gonna see like we're in [ __ ]
Guantanamo and you're gonna waterboard
me huh there's no water there's no board
go [ __ ] yourself
here's my smirk and I'm just gonna shake
my head at you like you're a [ __ ]
pathetic human being this is what I'm
doing right and this is the funny thing
I'm such a dick all I have to say to the
guy is I'm a comedian I'm gonna do a
sold-out show there and that would make
him back off but I'm a dick I'm like
[ __ ] this guy I want to see where this
is going so now he's all [ __ ] amped
up and he starts dropping f you know you
see saying the F word he sitting they go
to phew he goes you don't [ __ ] answer
my question right [ __ ] now I'm gonna
hit that call button we're sitting there
taxiing down the [ __ ] and getting in
line I'm gonna [ __ ] hit this [ __ ]
button if you blah blah blah blah and
I'm just [ __ ] mono Lisa's smile
smirking just shaking my head like you
are a [ __ ] [ __ ] right so now he's
saying the F word so much the lady who's
sitting in front of me diagonally in
front right in front of him turns around
and looks at us and now my heart's
racing
I'm like where's this going this is
gonna be great I am a hundred percent
[ __ ] innocent this guy's drunk and I
think he's gonna hit that button what's
gonna happen right I want to see what
the pilot looks like let's see where the
[ __ ] this is going right so he goes you
[ __ ] you
he sucks sucks bring his hand up to the
button goat I'm gonna hit that button
you don't think I'll [ __ ] do it I'll
hit that button and I'm sitting there
smirking and I'm thinking in my head go
ahead hit the [ __ ] button let's see
what happens let's see what happens
right so finally now he wants to hit the
button and he can't [ __ ] find it and
it's in in defense of him I couldn't
find it either I was looking up that I
half wanted to hit it myself then he
finally finally finds it and he hits it
right and now I'm just like holy [ __ ]
what's gonna happen and he's sitting
there going yeah huh you want to [ __ ]
play this game you want to [ __ ] play
this game and I'm surprised I mean it
took like [ __ ] like 30 seconds before
a flight attendant the one who gave him
the booze which evidently wasn't booze
comes over
and at this point we're like doing that
[ __ ] where we're behind a plane we're
almost ready to take off like we're
pulling up and then stop and pull it up
then stop and as planes have taken off
so she goes yeah what's the problem over
here and he goes uh I'm not comfortable
to fly with this guy this guy he's
fidgeting he's looking around another
[ __ ] people but blah blah blah Blee
is doing all this thing right and then
the stewardess looks at me and I'm just
sitting there [ __ ] my little smart
just shaking my head and I just looking
at just shaking my head like this guy's
out of his [ __ ] mind I don't say a
word
and this guy goes on and on and on about
his [ __ ] psycho babble about how I'm
the security risk so she goes - so she
goes okay any other passengers have you
noticed anything she's talking everybody
first class this is anybody noticed
anything odd about this guy and the lady
who was sitting right in front of the
dude diagonally from me
turns around she goes yeah I've been
listening to this guy bright berating
this other passenger she's on my side
and I haven't said a [ __ ] word this
is great
I'm just sitting there smirking and then
the lit stewardess looks at me and I
shrugged my shoulders like I don't know
what to tell you so finally she said sir
dude do you have anything to add to this
and I just said look I'm just a guy
trying to go to Indianapolis this guy
over here he starts slamming his doors I
kind of felt like a rat when I said that
I go slamming his doors next thing you
know he's dropping the f-bomb to me then
I'm thinking uh [ __ ] I just said bomb
right fortunately nothing happens so now
another [ __ ] the male stewardess
comes over right now he's going like
what's going on and the captain of the
[ __ ] now at this point we pulled over
and the plane has stopped 250 people
trying to get to Indianapolis and
jerk-off over here can't hold this
[ __ ] alcohol who just watched Person
of Interest
every every August evidently I have no
[ __ ] idea now the plane is stopped
this [ __ ] jerk-off has stopped the
plane interrogating a goddamn comedian
like I'm in the [ __ ] Taliban and like
he works for the CIA right so now we're
just sitting
and the captain is up front in the plane
like saying to the stewardess is going
basically relaying do I really have to
[ __ ] come back there this is the last
flight of the night is that really a
goddamn problem and that was the vaad
and they finally said to the douche sit
next to me are you gonna be okay to fly
with him and at that point it appeased
his [ __ ] ego that he was somehow in
control and he goes like you know what
okay it's fine it's fine
it'll be fine it'll be fine so they go
okay so now the planes going again and
now what now we [ __ ] come around and
he's sitting they have [ __ ] he's in
my ear and at this point I am lat like
the [ __ ] laugh he had me doing the
podcast that's what I'm doing and he's
sitting there going III he goes you know
what I'm glad I'm glad you say I hope
you [ __ ] do I hope you [ __ ] try
something [ __ ] try something one more
update I really hope you [ __ ] try
something and I'm just [ __ ] like
gut-busting laughing shake him it like
what are you gonna [ __ ] do to me what
are you gonna do to me
how are you gonna punch me in the face
you [ __ ] wiry jackass if you have
[ __ ] glasses on you know that's a
federal offense you're gonna go to jail
if you do that or something I don't know
what right so I'm just saying that
[ __ ] laughing the guy going I
actually at one point I put my [ __ ]
little eye pillow thing on do you know
like I'm going to sleep oh I had that
out too when the stewardess was talking
to me I was like putting it on is this
total mind [ __ ] like I I don't know what
this guy is I'm just trying to go to
Indianapolis I'm going to sleep and so I
got I got my [ __ ] eye thing on right
as he's sitting there threatening me
just I was going total passive
aggressive it's like dude I'm so not
concerned with you I'm literally putting
a blindfold on alright so this [ __ ]
guy he starts going he goes he goes you
think you [ __ ] won this you did you
[ __ ] won this he goes might you know
my dad is my daddy's son saying his
dad's some major CEO in Indianapolis
doesn't sound like a [ __ ] made-up
story I swear to god this is all true he
goes Mike my dad is some a major CEO in
Indianapolis and I will have you [ __ ]
arrested and the lady turns around again
you [ __ ] arrested the second weekend
on the ground I'm thinking like what for
what sitting here you [ __ ] loser
learn how to hold your alcohol alright
and he starts describing the view that
I'm gonna have when I go to jail like
some [ __ ] Law & Order episode oh
you're gonna love it
you'll be able to see Lucas Oil Field in
battle bat the bat and I'm just sitting
there cracking up laughing and then
there's this pause right
and I'm thinking finally he finally shut
the [ __ ] up it's like a three four
minute pause he finally just gave up cuz
I wasn't giving him anything I was just
laughing and shaking my head I was being
a dick to him I was because I was
enjoying it and then there was like a
three-minute pause and all of a sudden
he just goes why are you going to
Indianapolis bill so we're like 20
minutes into the flight and I gotta be
honest he's my adrenaline was so going
during all of that cuz I knew I didn't
do anything wrong but I thought we were
literally gonna go back and there was
gonna be [ __ ] cops there and if like
if if the [ __ ] stewardess or the
pilot asked me who I am and where I'm
going I'm gonna tell him I respect your
authority
you're just some general you don't have
any [ __ ] authority I don't have to
answer your questions it was problems
one of the most fun experiences I've
ever had with another human being like
when somebody thinks that they have
power and you know they don't and all
they can do is try to just keep bluffing
and raising their voice and start
cursing at you and if you just start
laughing at them the look on their face
is [ __ ] priceless
so Blasi said he said why are you going
to indianapolis bill right and i [ __ ]
started howling just [ __ ] hold in my
stomach shaking my head and with my
[ __ ] eye pillow thing on right and I
know I'm gonna get a ton of [ __ ] that I
wear one of those they're [ __ ]
underrated get the one at Brookstone
where it's literally a pillow I'm
telling you you could fall asleep 12noon
facing the Sun
awesome so anyways like after he asked
me what what you no way you're going
bill you're like it was like a ten
minute like probably ten minutes had
gone by and I can't [ __ ] sleep
because it's so funny to me I can't wait
to tell the story to every comic I know
I can't wait to try it on stage to see
if it's funny or whatever so finally I
just like that [ __ ] it maybe I'll just
get on my computer and I bring up my eye
pillow and I like I got a look at the
guy cuz I know he's [ __ ] staring at
me waiting for me to do something right
so I lift it up I get my [ __ ] mono
Lisa's smile going and I look over at
the guy and dude he is [ __ ] passed
out he looked like he got shot he was
sitting there like his head was just
hanging straight down and any time the
plane moved like his head was I mean he
literally got knocked out and for the
rest of the [ __ ] flight oh [ __ ] uh
what's Matt Damon's character isn't Jack
Ryan old [ __ ] Jack Ryan over here is
just you know the sky marshal the
[ __ ] booze bag and God knows what
else he was on he was just completely
out passed out for the rest of the
[ __ ] flight and this is what I want
you dick I am I was having so much fun
with this guy I start I can't sleep so I
start slamming waters because I want to
have to get up and take a piss just to
see if this guy's gonna freak out
because this security risk is getting up
and this the joke was on me he never
regained consciousness and then I really
had to take a piss but I'm such a
stubborn [ __ ] I was holding it cuz I
wanted to make sure he was awake when I
got up because I was gonna give him a
little smirk and then I was gonna get up
see if he hit the call button again but
he didn't he didn't wake up till we hit
the ground and and then it's funny then
he woke up and it was like four hours
later so now he had kind of slept off
whatever the [ __ ] this guy was on and
I'm sitting there smirking waiting for
the guy to start talking I mean he won't
look at me and I and I think at that
point he kind of [ __ ] realized that
maybe he got a little uh
a little extra little too patriotic so
we stopped we stopped at the gate and
everything and we're going to get up so
I grabbed my [ __ ] I get up and I'm just
kind of looking at him and he won't look
at me and then the lady who was sitting
in front of me had this big smile on her
face she goes how you she goes how you
doing I don't good I go that I go that
was an interesting one and I said it
really loud so the guy heard and he
didn't say anything and this is what he
did to try to save face his pillow was
kind of stuck behind it's kind of stuck
behind his shoulder in like a weird
place so he was frustrated with it so he
ripped it out from behind him and kind
of threw it down on the floor went yeah
like try to do some caveman grunt to try
to still have some sort of uh I don't
know what so so that was my flight to
Indianapolis people you know what how
far we did a [ __ ] podcast are we that
was a long that was a long [ __ ] story